greetings everyone and a special welcome
to all of our deadites and jaegers
watching today's show which features a
delectable diet of director debauchery
two horror helmers whose eclectic
careers have produced some of the more
memorable cinema of the past four
decades it's sam ramy taking on
guillermo del toro in this episode of
versus in one corner you have raymie
whose penchant for maximizing low
budgets began as a kid making movies
around his hometown of detroit and would
go on to bless us with movie franchises
like the evil dead drag me to hell and
those movies about the kid who shoots
the webs my name's the human spider i
don't care get out no he got my name
wrong
in the other corner it's del toro who
came onto the scene with his own low
budget masterpiece kronos before his
imagination took us to new heights with
hans labyrinth pacific rim and those
movies about that boy from hell sure
both of these shot callers love them
some horrific visuals but no one genre
can limit two talents like this and both
have high profile projects on the
horizon with sam ramey conjuring his
comic book adaptation skills once again
for doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness and guillermo del toro adapting
the psychological thriller nightmare
alley so while they're hard at work i'm
gonna have them compete against each
other well it might not be that bad
no
actually it might be kind of nice
yeah here's how we'll determine a winner
round one box office
round two tomato meter slash audience
score round three iconic moments round
four best characters and then we'll do a
wild card round something fun like which
director has made the best movie
featuring creepy long nails or fishy
bath time lovin or whose movies had the
most gallons of fake blood
at least i really hope it was fake blood
it's del toro versus rainey the golden
army taking on the army of darkness and
at the end of the five rounds we'll be
left with the quick and the dead
metaphorically speaking no one is
actually going to eat it here right this
is this is a safe space just a fun
little competition where the loser will
be dragged
okay it's too much
let's get it on we're gonna talk all
night because i'm really sleepy round
one box office
nothing puts booties in seats and
popcorn and mouths quite like the horror
genre and while sam raimi and guillermo
del toro have proven themselves masters
of many different sections of
blockbuster it can't be discounted that
their vibrant imaginations tend to lean
towards the scarier side of life or
death and audiences line up in droves to
see it as a matter of fact these two
guys would be pretty even in terms of
total box office dollars if not for that
one superhero franchise no not you blade
i'm talking about spider-man and his two
sequels rammy took the reigns of spidey
back when comic book movies as we know
them today were just cute little babies
if x-men was one small step for mutant
kind 2002's spider-man was a giant leap
for movie goers yearning for the day
when their favorite superhero stories
could be faithfully told on the big
screen raymie delivered as all three
spider-man flicks combined to gross over
1.6 billion dollars at the domestic box
office spider-man 2 gets the lion's
share of critical love but it's still
that first time we saw toby maguire punk
joe manganello that wins the title of
box office champ for either of today's
directors with that movie hauling in a
total of 662 million bucks okay blade
you can check into the ball game now del
toro did just the second installment in
the blade trilogy it was called blade 2
and it would go on to nabaku 129 million
dollars domestically which is still his
best highest grossing effort to date so
yeah guillermo has a marvelous mountain
to climb if he wants to steal this round
from ramy but del toro does have some
additional firepower pacific rim also
tops the 100 million dollar mark and
both of his hellboy flicks got oh so
close with hellboy 2 the golden army
jingling cash registers to the tune of
97 million dollars it's funny how movies
work because i know a bunch are
screaming uh wait until those evil dead
movies show up and you're right but not
necessarily in this round evil dead its
beloved sequel and army of darkness all
combine to just gross 46 million dollars
but don't worry sam stands there's one
more classic property up raymie's sleeve
remember the wizard of oz yeah he didn't
direct the 1939 classic but he did do oz
the great and powerful which conjured
265 million dollars at the box office
really i barely remember that movie
happening evil dead movies are out here
begging for change in oz's backstory
starring meg griffin as the wicked witch
that's what's selling tickets i mean i
do like the dog but wait was toto even
in that movie yet i don't understand the
kids anymore regardless that's a huge
chunk of change meanwhile del toro's
oscar winning this shape of water may
have been a celebrated achievement in
filmmaking but it's respectable 64
million dollars just doesn't sport the
firepower to play with well fire
guillermo del toro's total gross here in
the states is 630 million dollars making
for a rock solid 79 million dollar
average but his movies are expensive to
make too so craft services probably had
nothing left so they settled for check
cola and hydrox cookies sam raimi earned
a bountiful budget to make them spider
people movies and those helped propel
his total box office career earnings to
2.26 billion dollars averaging out to
174 million clams per film both del toro
and ramy's unique skill sets have
resulted in careers filled with genre
diversity and captivating story lines
and loads of cash but sam raimi getting
the keys to one of marvel's preeminent
characters made all the difference here
will we forgive him for the spider-man 3
emo dance sequence okay will we forget
it never ever never but he gets to win
in round one and he's your early leader
one to nothing
now you pissed me off
round two tomato meter slash audience
score well we've proven that both of our
competitors here today are good at
making movies that make money but money
can't buy happiness right i mean i'd be
willing to give it a shot in the
meantime what's also really nice is when
your peers in the critical world and
audiences across the globe like your
stuff because likes are just as good as
cash right
if you thought a combined three billion
dollar plus gross for these two fouls
was impressive get ready to be wowed
both rainy and del toro can brag about
having a fresh average for their movies
on both the tomato meter and audience
score metrics in fact they only have six
rotten movies between them and none of
those flicks fall below 45 percent on
the tomato meter unfortunately for sam
raimi he is responsible for five of
those six rotten movies but he's also
got that killer franchise in his back
pocket no no no not you now spider-man
we're talking evil dead baby the og and
its immediate sequel are at 95 percent
each on mita de tomato and kirsten
dunst's second outing is mj is at 93
cementing his ivy league level rep on
the tomato meter is dragged me to hell
at 92 percent and a simple plan at 91
percent but here comes guillermo del
toro whose hellboy movies landed 81 for
the original and 86 percent for the
sequel but he also has the celebrated
pan's labyrinth at 95
followed closely by the devil's backbone
and the shape of water both of which
land at 92 percent meanwhile rami's
other comic book fair include the
original spider-man at 90
spidey three at 63 percent still fresh
and dark man with an elephant earning b
average at 83 percent speaking of those
superhero movies blade 2 is the only
movie in del toro's entire catalog that
is rotten at the oh so closed a fresh
mark of 57 percent for his career
guillermo has an overall 80 percent
average on the tomato meter which tops
sam raimi's also impressive 75 average
despite his many critical darlings sam
also broke rotten with movies like oz
the great and whatever at 57
crime wave at 50
and for love of the game at 46 percent
wait wait for love of the game is rotten
the evil dead guy made an endearing
baseball film and y'all kevin costner's
pitching a perfect game and you're just
gonna ditch him after the fourth inning
i really don't understand kids now or
maybe i do because at least f-l-o-t-g's
audience scores 75
which is fresh which is why it deserves
its abbreviation keep throwing the heat
kev thanks mainly to the spider-man and
evil deads of the world sam raimi's
lifetime average is also fresh on the
audience score clocking in at 68
and on this scale it's actually a del
toro flick that sets the low bar with
1997's mimic notching just 37 with the
audience but here comes pan's labyrinth
striking again taking 91 percent of the
audience's love and helping guerrimo to
a 70 percent overall audience score
average which again tops his competitor
sam rambi can afford to make a few
clunkers and still remain fresh with
critics and audiences and now that i
know for love the game has been wronged
in the tomato meter i'm writing an angry
letter to my favorite podcast rotten
tomatoes is wrong hosted by
well you know
and then rate and review and say the
nice things check this show out gamer
del toro takes round two here and we got
us a tied ball game one to one
[Laughter]
you serious round three iconic moments
can we just take a moment to appreciate
the fact that we have two super fresh
directors on the show today look i love
doing verses but sometimes i gotta wear
a hazmat suit to check these movies out
not the case with sam and guillermo why
well in order to make a memorable film
it helps to pepper in those iconic
moments that stay with us long after the
lights go back up starting with drag me
to hell which is one long great moment
we'll we'll get to the evil dead we'll
get to the arachnid boys but the opening
shriek of the credits from drag me to
hell all the way through the incredibly
gory and satisfying conclusion you gotta
check that movie out the scene at the
bank where we meet the old lady can we
even call her old what's older than
elderly the super ancient lady and her
cursed fingernails cast such an eerie
cloud over the movie and then we do a
seance and an evil goat shows up one
long great moment that entire flick is
but so is pan's labyrinth whether it's
fawn giving ophelia a task or it's just
anything with the pale man pans maze is
a film designed to give your imagination
flights of fancy inspiration and
occasional tear and it's one of the
reasons why del toro is such a great
filmmaker movies like his two hellboy
flicks are packed wall-to-wall with so
much pure imagination willy wonka could
write a double album about it hellboy 2
the golden army has an angel of death
sequence that really does live up to
that description and the killing of the
forest god is a mythology soaked set
piece worth revisiting time and time
again and if you like a director's bold
bloody vision coming to glorious
practical effect life feast your eyes on
evil dead what sam raimi started with
the first film was taken to insane new
heights that cemented this franchise as
an all-time cult classic the worldwide
reach of moments in evil dead 2 like the
evil awakening was so profound it even
influenced a young predator natural
talent like guillermo del toro in fact
del toro is quoted as saying that evil
dead 2 sam raimi took the camera and
liberated it the stellar pov shots which
is hollywood talk for point of view put
us viewers right in the center of the
action making multiple moments come to
life or death as the case may be the
debate may rage over which cinematic
spider-man is the best in fact i believe
there's a versus episode on that very
topic spider-ham one i think but there's
no question that rammy's trilogy gave us
not only memorable moments but scenes so
special they continue to influence the
thriving comic book tentpole films of
today we can go action heavy like the
climactic train scene against doc ock
and spidey 2 or we can get romantic has
there ever been a kiss more custom made
to win the coveted mtv movie awards best
kiss
you don't dare throw twilight in there
no the answer is when spider-man kissed
mj in the rain while hanging upside down
and not even nickelback could make him
break character it's so good it may be
the best kiss i've ever had and i wasn't
even there i was just a kid shoving
popcorn into my face in the front row
saying oh one day i'll get to do that
guillermo can counter with a variety of
tactics whether it's the noble sacrifice
of leonard and mimik shout out to
charles s dutton the real hero of the
movie rudy or it's a rousing speech like
idris elba canceling the apocalypse in
pacific rim if the apocalypse is
anything like me it was secretly happy
to hear it had been canceled and it
simply went back to bed even films not
as well received like crimson peak had
breathtaking moments of gothic beauty
that can only hatch from a mind that is
creatively speaking one of the best in
the world but sam raimi gets the edge
here not just because he defied genre
and made me cry with every inning of an
aging pitcher attempting to toss a
perfect game as this estranged lover
watches from an airport bar but it's
simply a combination of his inventive
filmmaking techniques that were born out
of lower than low budget necessity and
his ability to take a well-known
property like the webby-handed photog
and give us brand new reasons to love
him guerre del toro's early effort
chronos has a sweet scene involving a
staircase and a scarab but if we're
talking best staircase moments ever then
i gotta once again drag you all to hell
the hooves are getting louder and louder
and oh my god the goat can climb
staircases is it too late to hire kevin
mcallister to rig up some paint cans sam
ramey wins round three by a razor thin
margin and he's up two to one
round four best characters moments are
great but they're not as easy to pin up
on a wall you can't sympathize with them
or say hey that's who i want to be when
i grow up moments are made because of
the characters that experience them
that's not only a senior quote that's 90
of the way there it's also an expert set
up for this round which will be
determined by which director had the
better set of players in their
respective filmography bonus points will
be awarded for those parts that were
built from scratch i want the ground up
here no pun intended evil dead hordes it
really means that spider-man may not get
his full due here although even norman
osborne would have to admit that peter
parker did grow by leaps and tall
building bounds in sam raimi's trilogy
and we the audience cared about him and
his aunt throughout the three films even
when it got all weird in spider-man 3.
seeing the origins of pete and his
family unit his frenemies the osborne
family and his pining for mj make us
feel like we're there we're cheering on
the newest superhero to hit the city
blocks we'd been aware of spider-man for
generations but these characters and
their journeys made the war feel fresh
but if it's glory one look no further
than pan's labyrinth ophelia is a sweet
character that we're intrinsically
rooting for but that film also marks one
of the many collaborations between del
toro and his creature muse doug jones he
plays the pale man here and he also
appears in such notable roles as abe
sapien in the hellboy flicks and the
murph thing who got very lucky in a
bathtub in the shape of water which by
the way is part of the genius of that
movie the moments of love discovery
longing that occur throughout the shape
of water matter to us because we want
these folks or things to succeed in
their goals freedom to do and love as
they please is a prominent theme but
it's brought to life and given emotional
weight because of how deathly del toro
fleshes out the characters ash from the
evil dead films is an absolute legend
and bruce campbell is always welcome at
a sam ramey barbecue he can pull off
exquisite horror action resulting in
extraneous amounts of blood and guts but
he can do it with a type of sarcasm and
quick wit that we all would hope to have
in that situation for my money the term
groovy is used better in evil dead than
it ever was at woodstock ramy scores
additional points for casting aces like
russell crowe sharon stone and a young
leonardo dicaprio in the quick and the
dead and billy bob thornton rightfully
earned an oscar nomination for his turn
in a simple plan but since we have sam
and guillermo here let's have some fun
with monsters
we have all sorts of cool vampires and
reapers in blade too and del toro also
gave us a captivating baddie in pan's
labyrinth with captain vidal the tooth
fairies and the golden army in hellboy 2
thomas sharp spooky ghost and crimson
peak and all the cool gigantic things
beating the crap out of each other in
pacific rim make for an impressive
resume raymie counters well with the
evil dead
necronomicon necronomicon y'all try to
say that 10 times in a row and obviously
mrs ganesh and her wonderful manicurist
and dragged me to hell you
shame me
okay fine i'll give venom and sandman
their due from spider-man 3. did we
mention alfred marlene's doctor octopus
yet if i didn't i should have because
he's great spider-man 2 is still
considered an all-time excellent comic
book movie and according to a certain
recent trailer doc ock may be back so
you know
now's a good time to get on his side and
book an appointment but what sways me
slightly towards del toro here is how
invested i get in his films even when i
had little to no context as to who the
hell any of these characters were going
to be when i entered the theater even if
hellboy and his cronies were based on
comic book lore i had no idea what i was
in for with those films although i did
thoroughly enjoy randy spider folk i was
training for that movie my whole life
pan's labyrinth on the other hand came
out of nowhere and gave me all the feels
the shape of water is also an emotional
gut punch and octavius spencer
rightfully deserved her award season
bounty for that performance sam raimi
gave us ash and a host of other
characters to cheer for not the least of
which is an aging pitcher on the mound
for perhaps the last time but guillermo
del toro's films are just too stuffed
with interesting characters born out of
an endless imagination that spills all
over the big screen plus the dude's name
at pacific rim is stacker pentecost are
you kidding me it sounds like a
quarterback on season 29 of friday night
lights but he's not he's a robot pilot
and his director wins round four we're
tied at two to two
that is the stupidest thing i ever heard
of jesus and now it's time for the wild
card round produce full disclosure i
read that like it was about fresh
veggies you know like the ones on the
tomato meter and thus i said produce
when in fact i actually should have
pronounced it produce as in the films
that either gama del toro or sam raimi
have been producers on usually i
wouldn't have something as meaningful
and important like a wild card round of
a beloved show rely on production
credits but these two gents they're no
ordinary executives they're not
producing movies just to collect a
paycheck they get their hands dirty and
they inspire nurture and ultimately help
make some pretty darn good cinema both
produced only a few movies before the
turn of the millennium so let's focus on
post y2k for now but we might time
travel back later
if the tec allows it
i laid it out pretty thick did you get
it i hope you did
sam raimi leaned into his horror
filmmaking expertise to lend a hand to
films like boogeyman and 30 days of
night as a producer and the two grudge
films he was an executive producer on
he's also credited as a producer for the
evil dead remake and i imagine he was
somewhat useful during the making of
that flick and coincidentally that was
his first fresh film as a producer since
he's done other fresh fairly the two
don't breathe films and the incomparably
fun swamp lizard scare fest crawl have
you seen crawl go check it out right
stop this show go watch crawl come on
back and finish up gamer del toro also
knows how to pick projects to produce
inside of his wheelhouse under a spell
and chronicas are fresh flicks on the
audience score and he was an executive
producer of 2007's excellent the
orphanage at 87 on the tomato meter and
if you needed more creepiness check out
the 75 fresh splice from 2009. but
whereas sam raimi has stayed relatively
inside his horror sci-fi realm del toro
has branched out in the last decade
producing movies you may not consider up
his alley like rise of the guardians and
kung fu panda 3 both of which are fresh
ramy keeps giving a strong fight with
movies like the messengers possession
and the poltergeist remake but all three
faltered on the tomato meter and are
what we in the biz call
rotten
del toro wins the battle of the
production tomato meter rather handily
with an overall 72 average to rammy's 40
but perhaps this whole round is gonna
come down to two movies so remember back
when i hit it at time travel it was done
with a purpose nothing on this show is
an accident except that time i wore my
shirt in a french tuck for three
straight inexplicable episodes the brass
told me it was the fashion i was
powerless but i'm of course referencing
the 1994 classic produced by sam ramey
time cop there's still time to save van
damme's wife who died a decade ago and
if we have any minutes left over let's
do some splits on the counter just how
we fought bad guys back in the day
despite its 45 tomato meter score
someone should do a podcast on that time
cop still holds up as an all-time
classic right up there with hard target
double impact and blood sport
the fact that van damme stars in most of
those movies pure coincidence so what
can possibly defeat time cop and give
del toro the win in this round and thus
the match well look you can't top a
time-traveling jean-claude van damme
with someone tougher because that person
doesn't exist but you can get cuter
witness the heart-melting eyes of puss
and boots look at that little face oh
he's got the little sword and the tiny
little boots i love him so much and i'm
a dog guy molly the wonder dog i hope
you're not watching right now i love you
the most sweetie stop hitting your ball
i fed you enough this morning the truth
is del toro and ramy are both
accomplished producers as well as
directors but if we're going by their
entire body of work i gotta give the
edge to del toro in this round his
movies cost a ton of money to make but
wow are they worth it he wins the round
and takes the trophy today because it's
right
here's the real truth you won't die but
let's all bow down before the greatness
it is sam raimi the dude made evil dead
for less money than i put in the parking
meter out front of this studio they
still won't validate my parking and it
inspired multiple generations of
filmmakers not the least of which is our
winner today guerra del toro remy also
gave us the template for the modern
comic book flick and the spider-man
trilogy is still a reliable playbook as
to what to do and maybe not to do in a
stellar superhero franchise but del toro
really hasn't missed the mark yet even
when we thought he might have misfired
with crimson peak that turned out to be
a beautiful work of art that just didn't
fit into the tiny box we had constructed
before the film was even released
guillermo edges out sam but that's just
one schlub's take
dam is currently on his way back through
time to change the outcome of this
episode i will quickly say thanks for
tuning into the show tell your friends
tell your family and any ghosts that may
currently be haunting your creepy house
hit me up on social media at mark ellis
live with your take and remember puss in
boots he's got his hat and he's got his
little felt and the tiny sword i just
want to snuggle the kitty
you